mac lesggy bonjour bonjour véronique
nous voici donc dans un charmant cadre
n'était pas tout à fait mais qu'est ce
que c'est mais qu'est ce que c'est un
salon de repos selon europol qui est
construit ça les étudiants en
architecture de l'école de versailles
d'accord donc nous sommes à versailles
sable à versailles ce avec six créations
d'étudiants versailles et 2 soit là
qu'ils ont pensé à notre repos à notre
confort et qui ont créé ces espèces de
petits transat fixe voilà dont on repart
aussi mais on va rester assis mais
normalement il s'écroulera après bon
vous n'êtes pas là par hasard
cet impôt deux choses oui vous avez été
versailles et à deux reprises tout à
fait nous en parlerons et vous êtes
aussi un fondu si on peut dire
d'architecturé oui voilà c'est un peu
votre patient une de mes passions une de
vos nombreuses passions la première
passion reste la science la science
exactement alors on va parler donc de
votre séjour à versailles donc vous avez
été étudiant exactement de biarritz vous
êtes venu à la faille de biarritz après
mon bac je suis arrivé à versailles en
79 ça n'est pas tout jeune voilà et j'ai
passé deux ans dans une école de
versailles voilà pour préparer mon
concours d'ingénieur agronome à l'école
cette école s'appelle aujourd'hui le
lycée privé sainte geneviève l'école
sainte-geneviève ginette pour les
intimes voilà j'en garde d'excellents
souvenirs souvenirs de stress aussi
parce que cette étude du travail est
intense voilà je crois que ce sont les
deux années où j'ai le plus travaillé de
ma vie à mais dieu merci j'avais trouvé
un dérivatif c'est que j'étais
responsables du ciné-club de ginette
donc j'organisais les projections du
mercredi après-midi
donc au fil des films qui passent et non
celle d'un petit cinéma qui a fermé qui
était à peine voilà et la cerise sur le
gâteau c'est est que en tant que
responsables du ciné-club j'avais une
carte qui me permettait d'entrer de
manière illimitée 7 jours sur 7 24
heures sur 24 en va autant que faire se
peut au cirano voilà donc comme il ya
pas de télévision à ginette ça m'a
permis devront pendant deux ans de faire
mon éducation cinématographique puisque
je passais mes week-ends
regardez 2,3 parfois quatre films voilà
donc à l'époque mais distraction enfin
ma distraction c'était le cinéma et le
reste du temps évidemment beaucoup de
travail donc au travail vous avez fait
quoi après alors sa maison alors
agronome
alors après ces deux ans donc j'ai passé
mon concours d'ingénieurs donc j'ai fait
une école de l'agronomie j'ai commencé à
travailler et c'est très amusant parce
que pour moi à l'époque versailles
c'était un espace qui était dédié un
travail vraiment intense et je l'avais
aujourd'hui je ne suis plus jamais je
reviendrai dans cet endroit où j'ai
travaillé aussi dur voilà mais les
années ont passé
les enfants sont arrivés la perspective
d'avoir une maison avec un jardin ça
fait de plus en plus pressante et donc
un moment je suis revenu à versailles
voilà en quête de verdure de calme la
tranquillité et l âge et donc habiter
dans des maisons pendant une bonne
dizaine d'années à versailles à l'époque
où mes enfants étaient petits
et je sais que vous avez aussi pas mal
profité du marché vous aimiez bien aller
faire vos courses sa direction de père
de famille alors oui moi j'étais alors
là j'ai vraiment découvert versailles
que vous avez aux trembles bien
évidemment quand on est étudiant on va
pour marcher la sortie c'est mme
mcdonald ça va au delà
d'ailleurs à l'époque même pas il n'y a
pas de mcdonald's à versailles la
situation a bien changé des pions donc
j'ai beaucoup profité du marché
j'ai beaucoup profité du parc aussi et
du grand-parc voilà je connais très bien
tous les fafn du parc de versailles
et puis comme vous dites effectivement
tous ces commerçants c'est caviste ces
marchands de primeurs sharks et a soigné
ses charcutier d'ailleurs j'ai beaucoup
mis à contribution un des charcutiers du
marché de versailles
oui parce que ça s'appelle la ferme des
bons veaux mais monsieur eric puisqu'un
jour ont cherché à filmer pour mon
émission est égal m6 la fabrication du
jambon que tous les agro-industriels du
jambon qui sont pas très enclins à
ouvrir leurs portes
vous avez fermé la porte de leur usine
et donc j'ai demandé à la ferme des
ponts homme si je pouvais en tant
qu'ancien client allait visiter leur
atelier de fabrication du jambon et donc
ils ont répondu très agréablement et on
est retourné depuis deux ou trois fois
par ans exactement
ouais et monsieur eric est un grand fan
et je me suis dit qu'un grand choix de
l'émission grand fan de vision alors
justement pour en revenir à votre
carrière
comment est venue cette se débuts à la
télévision parce que ce n'était pas du
tout votre du tout moi je travaille dans
le marketing des produits agricoles les
fruits et légumes les poulets l'avion
les éléments pour chiens et chats
et puis un jour j'ai répondu à une
petite annonce qui se proposait de
former des jeunes qui n'y connaissait
rien du tout aux métiers la télévision
et je me suis dit tiens benjamin savoir
faire dans ce qui concerne toutes les
études de marché des sondages je vais
aller à appliquer son savoir-faire à
l'étude de l'audience à la télévision en
faisant cette année une formation mais
là j'ai rencontré un vieil ami qui était
agronome comme moi qui mérite va plutôt
m'aider à développer un projet de
magazine scientifique que j'ai en projet
pour pau m6 et puis tant qu'à faire
avait-il une est rigolote va faire le
présentateur comme ça on économisera le
salaire d'un comédien benjamin tu crois
mais oui tu vas voir tu vas etre trés
bien et c'est donc on a fait un pilote
un numéro zéro qu'on a présenté à
l'époque alors je coupe pardon c'était
les débuts des listes alors c'était les
débuts de m6 m6 était encore très ouvert
à un ami
la petite chaîne qui monte
d'une nouvelle écriture etc nicolas
tavernost au havre on avait la volonté
de faire un magazine scientifique voilà
des comme il n'est pas beaucoup d'argent
moins qu'aujourd'hui même si aujourd'hui
c'est dur l'idée de confier ça à deux
jeunes ingénieurs un peu inexpérimentée
mais qui faisait l'émission rigolote
le rassemblent acceptable moi je pensais
que ça durerait six mois il conseille je
retournerai à mes chères études
marketing
est ce que vous aviez pris goût à ces
auteurs annie maltais alors présentateur
animateur rédac'chef aux journalistes
s'ils prenaient tous voila c'est quand
même très complet - la science j'ai
toujours une grande curiosité d'avoir
une grande curiosité tout court et
notamment pour les sciences donc
effectivement faire tout dans le métier
est ce qu'on faisait le montage est
extrêmement intéressant donc ça m'a
beaucoup intéressé il s'est trouvé que
l'émission était reconduite l'année
d'après il soit quoi je m'attendais pas
du tout mais l'audience était au rendez
vous puis une année puis une 2ème 3ème
4ème et c voilà ça fait bien ça ça fait
23 ans et demi que ça dure d'accord
toujours aux mêmes horaires soient un
jour de mourir de 1996 avant l'été les
dimanches matins on est passé le
dimanche à pois le dimanche soir
alors oui ça fait partie des alors on
n'est pas la plus vieille je crois que
l'atelier c'est le jour du seigneur
donc ça on peut pas lutter vous avez
thalassa vous voyez qui prévalait sur
bon voila mais nous on arrive juste en
dessous effectivement oui 22 23 ans est
un âge respectable pour une maison de
télé votre public
il est toujours aussi à l'enlever lui se
renouvelle voilà et le public se
renouvelle d'année en année et c'est
très amusant c'est qu'aujourd'hui je
vais t'en des bons des laboratoires où
je vois des jeunes doctorants qui me
lisent en mac lesggy mais je vous
regarde et quand j'étais petit et ça a
contribué à éveiller des vocations pour
la science si je suis ici c'est un peu
grâce à vous et c'est extrêmement
fréquents entre plaisir et alors déjà
petit vous étiez curieux comme ça de
tous à oui je pense que
c'est curieux depuis extrêmement
longtemps de beaucoup de choses vous
savez quand on habite loin en province
et pas pour d'autres distractions voilà
on a tendance à vouloir découvrir le
monde extérieur ça passe un petit peu
par la télévision ça passe beaucoup par
par les livres par les journaux et oui
oui j'ai eu cette curiosité depuis tout
petit je pense façon que si on est si on
veut être journaliste la première qui a
été de journalistes de qualité alors la
première alors la première c'est la
rigueur faut avoir une rigueur absolue
parce que ça ça ne supporte pas l'à peu
près parce que vous véhiculez de
l'information et quand on fait des
erreurs ce qui arrive de temps en temps
le moins possible mais qui arrive de
temps en temps dans le game 6 j'en suis
extrêmement mortifié voilà je fais en
sorte que le spécialiste regarder trouve
qu'il n'ya pas d'erreur et puis la
deuxième la deuxième qualité pour moi
évidemment impératif c'est la curiosité
si on n'est pas curieux le tout en
permanence là il faut pas être
aujourd'hui ça rien alors égale m6
d'accord mais suit vous avez des
présentes et proposer de nombreuses
émissions oui auparavant la maison la
plus originale les quizz les tests
depuis tout à fait à leur manière des
émissions sur laquelle on m'a demandé
d'intervenir comme vous avez raison le
site et la maison les plus originales
les grands tests voilà cela dit en tant
que producteur donc je les appelle ses
amis autre prédiction
voilà plus souhaité ce produit j'ai
produit mon jeu produit mon émission moi
j'aimais ma société et je me suis
intéressé au domaine du relooking
il ya très longtemps et dont je suis
leur producteur d'émissions qui
s'appelle nouveau logo nouvelle vie mais
pas celle destinée
alors voilà cordula exactement qui est
une émission dans lequel il ya en
quelque sorte d'unité puisque je voulais
vulgariser un petit peu le relooking et
on apprend vraiment alors ça l'est pas
scientifique mais il ya des techniques
victimes ont pour pour s'habiller pour
choisir les habits qui vont et christina
est une experte en la matière très bien
ça aussi c'est une émission qui dure
c'est une vision qui dure puisque ça
fait huit ans qu'elle durerait au moins
six mois et alors donc actuellement donc
le dimensions et quels sont vos projets
pour la rentrée
alors j'ai un projet qui me met qui
m'amuse qui m'intéresse beaucoup pour la
rentrée puisqu'une 2
mais maroc de mes passions c'est
l'histoire et je suis en train de
terminer nous mettre la dernière main à
une émission historique qui est très
originale puisqu'elle s'intéresse à la
vie quotidienne des français à une
époque donnée souvent l'histoire on la
connaît par le prisme des grands hommes
de louis xiv et napoléon
marie-antoinette voilà mais comment
vivent ces pas le peuple voilà à
l'époque par exemple le premier numéro
est consacré au siècle de louis xiv au
xviie siècle
écoutez c'est très gentil mais oui parce
que c'est vrai que c'est la ville c'est
la ville de louis xiv peut être délicat
comme peuvent l'être question peut être
que ça a joué voilà et on apprend des
choses par exemple on ne sait pas que
cette époque-là 95 % des français sont
des paysans qui habite à la campagne
alors que seulement 5 % d'entre eux
parlent le français
alors que moins d'un tiers sait lire et
écrire mon dieu voilà que les les
les aliments les plus basiques n'existe
pas par exemple les français mangent
jamais de boeuf par exemple voilà c'est
là qu'ont beaucoup trop luxueux même le
même les oeufs c'est un peu con c'est
vrai que caviar à l'époque
voilà vous voyez c'est tout à fait à
l'opposé la houle qui travaillent ce
moment intéressant et ça va s'appeler
comment ça va s'appeler l'histoire au
quotidien d'accord et ça va passer on
sait déjà et ça va passer à la rentrée
quel jour keller annonçant à trois
semaines avant la télévision mais jamais
quand ça passe à moins de trois semaines
n'ont bien sûr concurrence oblige voilà
une fois tous les mardis les productions
que milliers pour les transmettre
comment se positionner en conséquence
voilà très bien donc au niveau
production vous continuez nouveau look
nouvelle vie au niveau production
j'espère bien continuer nouveau look
pour une nouvelle vie mais c'est une
excellente émission à re re re le
produit qui s'appelle magnifique et
christina c'est une émission qui est
diffusée sur téva et c'est une émission
dans laquelle christina donne vraiment
des conseils de mode et de tendances
accessible à tous alors on s'amuse avec
l'été le
le look des stars on donne des conseils
de bien-être on dit par exemple que vont
choisir je veux que ce soit une mission
extrêmement pratique donc on dit par
exemple comment choisir le vol le bon
jean en fonction de votre morphologie
parce que tous les types de jean n'ont
pas tous les dj voilà et c'est pareil
pour les pulls à col roulé les
décolletés les veste et chemise y est
voilà donc c'est vraiment la première
émission de qui vulgarise la mode comme
j'essaie à mon modeste niveau de
vulgariser la science
très bien nous écouter que ferions nous
sans vous bah écoutez je ne sais pas
celle des mondes
voilà j'espère continuer à éveiller
l'intérêt des téléspectateurs le plus
longtemps possible à tous les niveaux
merci mac mais je vous en prie véronique
bayern mais faire partager ça fait
toujours du bien
progrès se ressourcer à versailles sans
teliad ça ce n'est pas bon merci je vous
en prie
à bientôt